all right Yellow Jackets fans I I I'm
not gonna waste any amount of time
because holy wow did some weird and
shocking things happen in episode six so
welcome back to heavy spoilers your home
for the heaviest of spoilers and in this
video we're going to be discussing
everything in Yellowjackets episode six
full-on story breakdown callbacks
strange references and parallels and
some out their theories get that kitty
pool ready because Shauna is having a
home birth anyway if you enjoyed this
video hitting that like button is much
appreciated and subscribe to heavy
spoilers to stay up to date on all of
our Yellow Jackets coverage with all of
that out of the way thank you so much
for clicking this I'm your host Jared
now let's get into Yellowjackets episode
six so last week things ended with
Shawna going into labor and basically
the entire Wilderness story this week is
around her birthing this Wilderness baby
Misty is put in charge of the delivery
because she is by far the one with the
most survivalist skills in the
wilderness now this makes sense because
in the birthing class to start this
episode she's one of the few actually
paying attention to the video however
when she physically sees blood on her
hands this is metaphorically symbolizing
that the blood that she has on her hands
from the death of Crystal so that uh
causes her to kind of spiral from
leading the baby delivery now during
this weird and I mean weird things begin
to happen like Travis Lottie and her
followers making a similar blood
sacrifice to the Wilderness on an animal
skull offering it blood locks of hair a
button and some other things along with
everyone chanting to the Wilderness
hearing them and vice versa and we do
know that the latter half of this
episode is entirely in Shauna's mind
well I'm convinced that even the ritual
part is brought on by a dream too
because Shauna is an unreliable narrator
in this episode and is hallucinating
because someone slipped something into
her tea if you take a close look when
Misty is about to have a panic attack
Shauna takes a drink of something and
then all of the weird stuff begins to
happen after this leading to her passing
out and us getting the uh It's a
Wonderful Life like second half of this
episode and all of this strangely goes
deeper because a couple weeks ago I
mentioned the movie Rosemary's Baby and
how there was a movie poster of this in
Vans video store along with Lottie very
much acting similar to characters from
that movie well a large portion of this
seems to be taking influences from that
movie specifically the birth the weird
ritualists obsessed with her baby and
the ending like the ending of Shauna
humming mirrors that of Rosemary's
Babies ending
hmm
[Music]
I also see the baby Buffet scene
mirroring that of 2017's Mother where
the same fate happens to their baby but
all of that is uh religious symbolism
for the you know body and blood of
Christ which honestly could have the
same meaning here hella even Rosemary's
Baby she talks about the baby's eyes
what's wrong with the baby's eyes and
Sean is stillborn baby could actually be
the no eyes man but that is a huge and I
mean huge stretch but yeah Shauna's baby
does not make it and a lot of the
Wilderness weirdness in this episode is
being chalked up as hallucinations you
know what argue in the comments if you
think I'm off my rocker I'd love to hear
why or why not but there's another thing
and this is layers deep my friend so
follow me but all of this episode or at
least the Wilderness portions were
purposely done as a parody in a sense
not in a comedic manner but to reenact a
plot of a movie in this case Rosemary's
Baby into tricking the audience and
again throwing in some movie parallels
that we've seen done a handful of other
times in season two so the Wilderness
birth opens with blurs Song 2 which was
originally intended as a parody of 90s
American grunge scene which is where the
Yellow Jackets opening theme takes
inspiration so setting the stage with
this parody song then leads us into the
reenactment of Rosemary's Baby and
ending with a one shot that honestly
feels more akin to a play or musical and
the panning away just just feels
feels odd Shauna claiming that she can
still hear the baby crying is actually a
common occurrence among still births but
again it is ramped up in such a dramatic
theatrical manner I I think that this is
theater and if so I nailed it I told you
I don't know I mean uh Lottie even said
multiple times that none of this is real
so I I don't know again let me know how
wrong I am in the comments we gotta get
Mystery Ink on this one Shauna Cali and
Jeff's through line in this episode is
fairly straightforward though though the
police with Jay and Kevin are on to them
and they gotta go down to the station to
answer questions of course Shauna
reverts a bit viewing Cali as more of an
object than a daughter saying that she
wished she would have slept with Jay
like damn Shawna like come on she's
family but all of the inadmissible
information still feels like a Breaking
Point to me like any and all of the
Intel Jay had gathered is hella sketchy
so uh him he's just kind of dirty in
general the questioning between the two
pairs is very much framed in a good cop
slash bad cop or sassy cop when we're
talking about Jay now the thing I find
odd is yes Jay did get Shauna to admit
to the affair and her being connected to
Adam but aside from that Jay doesn't
have any hardcore evidence that she is
responsible for his disappearance Shauna
is a hell of a suspect don't get me
wrong but no body means no crime to me
in this case and when she's talking
about not wanting the life that she was
dealt a child a marriage this all stems
back to the Wilderness and her having
the PTSD of losing her firstborn there
what I take away from this whole
interrogation is that Jay is on her
Trail but no concrete evidence and while
Shauna is spiraling in the van the gun
in the glove box is literally a
chekhov's gun at this point showing up
time and time again so it's bound to be
used by the end of this season and this
is an out there guess it's used on Jay
and somehow Kevin is framed using the
missing bullet casing from season one I
I don't know man or just I don't know
we're all just guessing at this point
now coach Scott doesn't get much of the
spotlight in this episode but what he
does get is a complete jumble of
present-day cabin mixed with his
memories or even the different timeline
I mentioned like last week Madonna's
Rescue Me begins to play which is the
first clue to as where coach Scott's
mind is at right now with the song being
about someone being saved by love from
their loneliness and as we can see coach
Scott trying to use his loving memories
to help distract him from his current
nightmare that he is in the game of
shrades that they play throws a bevy of
movie titles out each having elements
that relate to his current situation and
or the Wilderness setting scanners and
The Shining are both about people losing
portions of their psychosis in different
situations while The Shining also has
you know them stranded in the middle of
nowhere during a snowstorm element
Falling Down is about a man who's just
had enough snaps and goes on a rampage
Silence of the Lambs has Hannibal Lecter
someone who also enjoys the taste of
human flesh hear no evil is about a deaf
woman who is being stalked by a
mysterious person which we could kind of
compare this to the evil Spirit stalking
the girls in the wilderness and then
leading into present day One Life to
Live can be taken at face value with
Coach Scott only having his One Life to
Live and unfortunately he picked the
wrong path his career over love an
airplane is of course how they crash
landed Into the Wilderness to begin with
again there's the weird TV static that
seems to interrupt coach Scott's
memories of which I've considered maybe
two different timelines smashing
together I still got my money on that
theory I'm betting big but the better
answer right now is that coach Scott may
be suffering from one refinia I'm sure I
pronounced that hella incorrectly but
it's the state of where a person becomes
confused about the distinction between
reality and their dreams as if he or she
was living in a dream state caused by
several different things one of which
being prolonged sleep deprivation this
appears more and more as coach Scott's
mental state is dwindle plus the word
has Greek Origins to it and there has
been other I mean a handful of things
that have had kind of Greek influences
in this show so uh we'll see oh and one
ironic thing that I caught is that coach
Scott in the beginning is standing side
by side with the health class skeleton
and the framing is is purposeful
foreshadowing that this poor guy is
going to be nothing but bones soon again
there was a flash frame back in episode
3 that we found hinting at this fate and
uh yeah my my bet is saying that coach
Scott is not making it out of episode or
not episode but season two alive Misty
is maybe my favorite character in this
whole episode because she of course
willingly joins lottie's cult to save
her friend Natalie but almost as though
she's being placed in prison and loves
every second of it when she checks in
all of her weapons and drug
paraphernalia are handed over even
seeing her fentanyl serene from season
one then her knowing the warden AKA
Lottie and one of the newer inmates AKA
Natalie makes her a bit of a legend
amongst the other Purple People members
telling stories and almost being a
celebrity in the mess hall with all of
the other quote inmates being in her
Posse Misty is running the yard right
now she is loving it wearing purple
instantly getting the attention
something much like she got when she was
in the wilderness and she's craved it
ever since though Misty is again being
manipulated by Lottie much like Natalie
obviously Misty knows none of this is
sunshine and rainbows there's something
nefarious behind what Lottie has planned
or what she's doing here but is
persuaded into stain because of Natalie
using the Friendship card the reason
Lottie wanted Misty to stay is because
she has or had some sort of vision of
her involving her something some sort of
vision here we don't know what it is
maybe Gathering all of them into one
place like we see at the end of this
episode but Lottie definitely has
something she isn't letting on to in
this first meeting scene with Misty
later in the crying Circle one of the
Purple People urges Misty to cry about
her breakup with Walter but that's not
the reason this small scene affected
Misty so much she is instead remembering
crystal unaliving in the wilderness the
words from the crying woman are exactly
how Misty feels but she's completely
turned off her emotions in present day
[Music]
that's why later Natalie mentions we're
all like this meaning damaged goods or
cursed they haven't shed the horrors of
the past instead just buried them down
hoping that they won't return it's a
stark difference between how Natalie and
Misty are acting so we'll see if Misty's
happy Celebrity Status Fades sooner
rather than later Natalie on the other
hand is spiraling a bit from last week's
meditation exercise with Lottie now
knowing what she was right about the
evil spirit having been with them ever
since they left the Wilderness this has
obviously spooked her because she is far
different from her usual sarcastic dry
self instead shooting the rifle for
practice Natalie watching her shoot has
lost her Mojo I've lost my JoJo
compared to her younger counterpart
Natalie is a horrible shot I I have a
feeling this panicked mentality is
because she knows that the evil spirit
will somehow come back in maybe a
physical form aka the antler Queen and
she is prepping Natalie is also torn
about Travis of course and I think that
this goes deeper some of the commenters
from last week suggested that the reason
Natalie was trying to corrupt Travis in
the flashback drug scenes is because he
was dating Lottie at this time that's
why she feels so selfish for what she
did but also the beef that she had with
Lottie makes a heck of a lot more sense
and at first she doesn't own up to it we
saw so much
we did so much [__] up
again only a theory but would reinforce
the guilty consciousness of the past
that we've mentioned with Misty Natalie
is healing when she is surrendering to
lottie's teachings and wearings in
purple and that's why when later she has
the one-on-one talk with Lisa Natalie
has kind of reverted back a bit you know
shedding the purple wearing only black
and being a bit more standoffish it's
only when Lisa reassures her about
suffering that Natalie sees things
clearer
because suffering is inevitable
and only by meeting it with compassion
can we truly begin to grow the Goldfish
babysitting also reinforces this I think
the biggest uh what what is going on
here of this episode though is Lottie
talking to her therapist again just
something about the darker office
setting the clothing she's wearing and
the way she talks makes me think that
this is more in lottie's mind than the
actual therapist's office in episode 4
Lottie and her therapists are wearing
white it's a brighter feel more vibrant
more of a pure conversation ladia and
her mirror each other both wearing white
sitting across from one another but in
this episode it's more of a maroon
darker coloring of clothing on both of
them without the camera showing the
therapist and I'm convinced that this is
all in lottie's mind and her realizing
the past was in fact real and the evil
spirit is in fact at work has her
spooked hell the therapist could even be
the evil spirit casually twisting and
guiding Lottie into whatever it did back
in the wilderness even parts of the
couch desk and the plant in the corner
are a bit different from their first
meeting I mean she mentioned that God
the god of the place had them doing
unspeakable things which I think
reinforces that Lottie is not the antler
Queen but rather the mysterious spirit
is the antler Queen and all of them were
at the will of its mercy and she's
slowly figuring out by Rare happenstance
that all of the surviving members are
finding their way back to her and the
spirit personally I think that the
spirit is in lottie's driver's seat
because last week Misty mentioned that
the last time she heard about Lottie was
that she was barely coherent in a mental
facility while van and Ty also seemed
shocked that Lottie is back and
seemingly all is well I mean the last
shot of this episode yeah there's
there's definitely some evil lingering
in her van and taisa have a bit of a
catching up to do after the evening of
Tai kissing her and Whispering this
isn't where we're supposed to be now
last week we theorized that she was
referring to the pair are supposed to be
at lottie's compound rather than that of
Van's video store and that's exactly the
case by the end of this episode Ty's
sleepwalking Persona who I'm assuming
has either an open line of communication
with the evil spirit or is run by the
evil spirit purposely needed to get Van
Into The Mix so all of this big old
detour makes sense but why why is the
real question here we can kind of
conclude that yes before Ty was married
van and her were romantically involved
and of course had a falling out now I'm
curious if van wanted to continue living
in the past hence opening the video
store and being surrounded by Nostalgia
while Tai wanted to live for the future
but instead purposely made herself so
busy and stressed via politics that she
would then forget about the Wilderness
which doesn't she have responsibilities
back in New Jersey and what about her
family anyway each have solutions to
what happened in the wilderness but are
drastically on different sides of the
solutions you know living in the past
forgetting about it the happy Nostalgia
and just being too busy to remember but
there are a few things of note amongst
Vans VHS Nostalgia collection to point
out like the poster of airplane which
both references the Wilderness and Coach
Scott's hallucinations VHS box copies of
Clueless Casper and Antarctica relating
to Tai being clueless of Van's New Life
Casper maybe being the evil spirit
influencing each of the core
Yellowjackets moves and Antarctica
relating to the frigid Wilderness where
they were trapped Tai also jokes about
Sandra Bullock and miss Congeniality I
give up uh does Miss Congeniality go in
Sandy good or Sandy bed
which could be a little hint hint at
Ty's good and bad personas now in the
background if you listen closely white
Town's your woman plays bang up song I
still listen to it every day but it
alludes to how Ty and Van were at one
point hopelessly in love but Ty probably
broke it off due to reasons I mentioned
earlier and Van says that there's no us
anymore Misty calling both Ty and her
having the same response about I thought
she was makes me think that they knew
Lottie had 100 lost her marbles so
something is up again I'm saying the
spirit is driving Lottie influencing the
others because Ty calling Shauna to get
her there is the last surviving member
that we know of in present day there's
also some subtle character backstory for
van when they're driving to lotties with
her claiming that yes she is dating
she's getting out there even though she
still has a broken heart on the radio
pitch Sula by Elliot Smith plays which
highlights both the fear of hurting the
other person and of being hurt again due
to someone's own insecurities which
again is why van is clearly living in
the 90s Nostalgia World surrounded by
the good not the memories of the bad
when they all arrive to lotties I want
to say each of them has an entirely
different feeling of being there and
seen Lottie hell I think I think Van's
expression is the best saying keep your
eye peeled for the black and white Nikes
which is a reference to the 1997
Heaven's Gate cult where a mass
unaliving of roughly 39 people occurred
all wearing identical black shirts
sweatpants and brand new black and white
Nike athletic shoes so van is not
drinking any of lottie's Kool-Aid but
also maybe the most scared of the group
seeing Lottie after all of these years
to me this whole sequence this whole
thing feels like The Avengers me Thanos
in the final showdown
but let's talk about lottie's clothing
Choice ditching the orange sunlight
coloring for something darker blue
purple shades of green thrown in there
to me this is a full on 90s Disney
villain whom all of which you know stuck
to this same kind of color palette via
animation so her clothing change
combined with the ominous music from the
Wilderness spells absolutely spells
disaster for the other five Yellow
Jackets why the DraStic change of
clothing all of a sudden I think the
evil spirit influencing her knew just
knew already that the others were on
their way and was primed for their
arrival but the biggest reveal is
probably the overhead shot at the end of
this scene last week Paul good old Paul
King of spoilers here at heavy spoilers
suggested and theorized that her
speaking and meeting place to start the
season was in the shape of the
mysterious symbols and holy wow was he
right a bit different than what we had
theorized but the overhead shot shows
that lottie's compound is entirely laid
out to form the same cryptic symbol from
the Wilderness it was right in front of
us the whole time like we were staring
at it even the cabins Lake tree stump
are all playing parts of the Wilderness
again there is no concrete Clues but I'm
saying when Lottie was in the mental
facility something latched onto her
broken mind
urging her to create this Wellness
Retreat knowing that she could create
her own Hive with the other original
Yellowjackets slowly finding their way
back to the hive wild stuff I'm telling
you wild stuff is in store for next week
so drop your craziest theories in the
comments I I want to hear them all but
yeah I I really hate to say this but for
the maybe third week in a row I'm saying
something fishy is up with all of the
pop culture movies television musicals
and play symbolism and references that
there's got to be something to it right
like the static effect that jumps from
reality into someone's deceptive reality
especially with this episode again
having a Truman Show poster hint hint
and the way that this episode ends with
a one shot on Shauna feels uh very like
end of a musical or play maybe I'm
grasping at nothing here but something
just just something feels off about this
episode in general like sure Shana
hallucinated a lot of the birth but
I don't know it it feels I I don't know
it just feels weird anyway that is
episode six of season two personally I
think that this episode was the most
disjointed so far in season two with
some of the events being dragged out far
longer than they could be but I think
we'll really start to get moving with
all of the surviving members now at
lottie's and we're bound I'm telling you
we are bound to see whatever the heck
Supernatural stuff she has up those
sleeves fingers crossed for these last
four episodes to go full on banana
sandwiches crazy but yeah what did uh
what did you think of episode six and
what sort of theories or ideas or things
we maybe missed that were shown in this
episode let us know in the comments down
below and I'll let you know we're
currently running a competition giving
away three copies of quantum Mania
Ant-Man quantumania on the 15th of May
and all you got to do to get a chance of
winning this is like this video
subscribe with notifications on drop a
comment below on yellowjack it's episode
six we pick the comments at random at
the end of every single month in the
winners of last month are on screen
right now so if that's you message us on
Twitter at heavy spoilers if you want
something else to watch be sure to check
out some of our other cool videos we
just did an exorcist breakdown Paul did
really good work on that one go check it
out but with all of that out of the way
thank you so much for your constant
support I've been Jared I'll see in the
next one take care and peace